[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'étais dans mon lit comme tout le monde
j'ai entendu quelques bruits mais je
pouvais pas définir ce que c'était parce
qu'il y avait quand même un petit peu de
vent
j'ai ouvert les volets de ma chambre qui
demeure heureusement n'était pas
électrique et là ce moment là j'ai
compris ce qui se passait c'est dans ma
cour il y avait la porte avait été
arrachée il y avait les poubelles des
restaurateurs et le congélateur
bon ça m'a pas tellement émotionné du
balcon de notre maison nous avons aperçu
dans jardin un bateau qui naviguait tout
seul on s'est aperçu effectivement que
ce bateau était tout simplement le le
bateau de nos voisins qui lui même avait
pris les flots sans capitaine il y avait
une porte qui était il avait explosé
avec la pression de l'eau et tout à
l'intérieur étaient chavirer il faut
dire les armoires tout à fait flotter
c'était pour moi voir la nuit du 28
février 2010 la violence d'une vague a
retourné le village de boyardville
on
dans les charentes maritimes la tempête
nommée xynthia a fait 47 morts
elle a détruit des maisons en a fissuré
d'autres les habitants de boyardville
ont vécu avec xynthia un cataclysme qui
n'avait jamais imaginé
certaines personnes ont passé la nuit
sur des armoires attendre que le
redescende
d'autres ont dû sortir de chez elles en
bateau quatre mois après les stigmates
de la tempête ont presque disparu
la vie à boyardville a repris son cours
il ne reste que quelques traces de la
montée des eaux sur les murs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
face à la catastrophe
l'état a classé les quartiers sinistrés
en zone noire sans prendre le temps de
la concertation il décide d'exproprier
les habitants et de raser les 150
maisons de la zone
madeleine françoise joël devrait partir
devenant les premiers réfugiés
climatiques français c'était un
sentiment d'injustice puisque y avait
rien qui prouvait pas qu'ils pouvaient
prouver leur décision ils ont décidé ça
mais on est on a bien été obligé de les
entendre dont les a jamais accepté
jamais moi j'ai toujours dit partout
n'importe qui l'interviewait que je
restais chez moi c'est en 1906 1910 que
paris a été inondé
est ce que vous avez entendu dire qu'on
allait à battle paris no on veut nous
sauver nous sauver mon âge met en danger
ma femme
est né ici et on va la garder
c'est une maison de famille et pas du
tout s'en aller on peut rester là
voulez-vous à 70 ans et je m'en aille ou
qu'on leur trouve une maison pareil j'en
trouvais pas ma vie elle a été là et
puis bon je finirai là
[Musique]
le passage de xynthia a engendré un
formidable élan de solidarité dans les
premiers jours tout le monde est venu
prêter main forte plus touchées à portée
du café des vêtements offrir le gîte et
le couvert
puis des associations se sont formés
pour lutter contre les zones noires
imposées par l'état c'est au noir ont
été délimitées dans l'urgence un mois
après la tempête
par cette action l'état a voulu montrer
qu'il ne restait pas inactif qu'il avait
pris conscience du danger mais il a
oublié un détail
l'attachement des gens à leur maison
leur village leur vie de déracinement et
plus violent encore que la tempête pour
les habitants de boyardville
l'idée de tout perdre est bien plus
forte que le danger potentiel de rester
sur place comme dans d'autres pays
touchés par des catastrophes naturelles
leur réaction a été la même l'unité nous
avons créé l'association pour la défense
quand nous avons appris le zonage c'est
surtout ça qui nous a choqués on n'a
plus été choqués par le 1er avril que le
28 février en réalité le 1er avril c'est
l annonce par la radio de cette fameuse
zone
je crois qu'elle était noire au départ
cette zone noire normalement signifie à
l'heure actuelle que on a des chances de
ne pas pouvoir garder notre maison ils
disent ne pas vouloir la raser mais
enfin on peut être expulsé quand même on
a monté de multiples dossiers qu'on a
été porté en préfecture en sous
préfecture
au conseil général on a eu plusieurs
rendez vous avec toutes ces
personnalités
à l'heure actuelle on semble revenir au
cas par cas
c'est à dire qu' il devrait y avoir un
expert qui devrait passer pour pouvoir
examiner chaque propriété et savoir si
telle et telle propriété est réellement
en danger
jusqu'à présent on attend les réponses
[Musique]
certains habitants reprochent à l'état
d'avoir mal maîtriser les conséquences
de la tempête
depuis plusieurs siècles une digue en
cercle boyarville les ancêtres avaient
construit tout un réseau d'évacuation
des eaux en cas d'inondation des
canalisations souterraines appelé les
varaignes qui fonctionne un peu comme
des écluses aurait dû être utilisé
d'après jean-pierre un gros tuyau de la
grandeur qu'il fait exactement et il ya
un clapet quand la mer monte
le clapet ce fort sur le tuyau et l'eau
ne peut pas après et dès que la pression
est forte ici
le clap et se repoussent elle allait
leur part partir alors les anciens
l'avaient fait c'est donc que c'était
utile s'est entretenu jusque dans les
années 70 par là et depuis depuis que la
murette est faite que derrière ces
englobée dans une propriété et plus
personne n'y a accès donc on ne peut
plus nourrir comme on est comme on veut
et bien j'ai suggéré de lever cette
vanne avec un tractopelle on m'a répondu
qu'on ne pouvait pas alors ils ont
préféré ouvrir une brèche un petit peu
plus loin dans la digue qui est qui et
qui va au championnat pour faire partir
l'eau abalo est parti aussitôt alami 2h
pour partir la leur et mis trois 3 jours
mais par contre on a bu à cette marée
consécutive
chaque fois que la mer remonte et hop
lolo remonter dans les yeux dans les
maisons
[Musique]
face aux protestations des habitants de
boyardville
l'état fait marche arrière et a déclassé
les zones noires madeleine françoise
joël et leurs voisins ne seront pas les
premiers réfugiés climatiques français
ils peuvent rester dans leurs maisons
soulagés ils ont repris le cours de leur
vie reste le souvenir de ce mauvais rêve
nommé xynthia qui s'efface peu à peu
seront ils à nouveau touché aucun
d'entre nous ne s'est trouvé en danger
pendant cette nuit de raz-de-marée si on
peut dire
moi personnellement je pense pas que ça
se reproduira arrivera ce qui doit
arriver malheureusement on n'y peut rien
il ya des cycles faudra bien les subir
c'est pas une tempête parce qu'elle est
là et le vent était bien moins fort par
99 et on pense plutôt à un tsunami est
simple il ya pour moi c'est un truc
gobain par tellement cliquable disons
qu'elle allait l'ailé le phénomène des
grandes marées de des basses pressions
du pla maire
mais ce qui est un petit peu bizarre
c'est quand même qu'ils ont pêché à la
costumière de poissons qui faisait qui
se pêchent dans les grands fonds par
trente mètres de fond là il ya quelque
chose qui est un peu flou
[Musique]